[Music]
these are star display by speeders led
poi USB rechargeable soft fiber-optic
heads it's all modular you can take
these off both ends a nice soft string
leash system with ball bearing swivels
at the top and bottom and then they came
with a single loop but it also came with
a kit you can just replace it with a
silicon ball grip now I've gone and
modified mine a little bit which I could
have waited till after the review but
I'm such a modifier I gave a bit of a
haircut to the fiber optics I'm do so at
your own risk and they've got their
attempt at a adjustable system here but
once I had the length I liked I just
snipped mine you could take the fiber
optic off string off and I could put
them inside super sake start ass fiber
optic play what else to say they also
come with a very helpful bag the fiber
optics are a bit delicate and the bags
contoured such that if the head stay at
one end and the fiber optics go down to
the other the only thing I would have
reversed the zipper because I find it a
bit finicky factually zip up it's got a
bit more of a DIY look and some of the
products on the market but they might
last forever I have no I got these two
weeks ago I just don't know yet so I
think it's a cool product it's just
certain time for Christmas of course use
my code I make a commission and you save
10% if you use the code I've got a few
here too just to confirm I'm a boy
spinner and also I love fiber flies when
I got this is like it's perfect it's
like both and with the sound oh yeah
they make a swishing noise so there is
the interesting things and for me to
share
all new people and just started about
boy this is great product yeah
thank you yeah good first time toy much
are else to say I hope you're having a
good day wherever you are
better better okay
[Music]
you